how do you go alien I don't know alien
genetics neither to you we're not gonna
know until one of us puts our thing in
one of their 15 holes well you know
folks space technology is really
advancing got that nice photo of Pluto
found water on Mars we are going places
so I think we all know we've got to ask
ourselves one question would you [ __ ]
alien
[Music]
you're a consenting alien I would have
sex with you I wouldn't have sex with
them Pro alien [ __ ] team not putting
my dick inside of an alien
I would [ __ ] an alien and I would not
[ __ ] an unidentified for an object I
would [ __ ] an alien [ __ ] an alien is
very irresponsible we've made contact
with alien life oh my god and your first
response is you want to [ __ ] it why not
there are a lot of steps to go through
before we even consider [ __ ] an alien
if they wanted to talk to us they would
have talked to us by now which means
they're only coming here to do one thing
one thing only in the scenario that
aliens come to earth and say hey we just
want to [ __ ] you it's cool something's
up being less intelligent than humans
they maybe don't understand the
consequences of possible conception STDs
moral and emotional consequences they're
obviously gonna be more advanced than we
are they came here we're certainly not
going to them maybe we're going them
NASA's defunded man yeah have at SpaceX
it's true but they keep blowing up and
when they land let's talk about the
genitalia we don't know what they got
exactly isn't that exciting so exciting
they could have barbed wire dicks assume
you can they can wield one of these
wheeled it sounds so violent who's to
say that aliens semen isn't toxic to
human beings maybe it's like fiberglass
maybe you won't know until like a week
later when it's itches really bad well
then you know what oopsie-doopsie I'd be
very surprised if their concept of sex
even involved ejaculation right would
you still feel comfortable having sex
with a male alien or maybe a gender
non-conforming alien I think that that's
also something to bring up it could be
the kind of thing you don't have like
Prague mentions have sex the female rips
the male's [ __ ] head off and he said
sure we would communicate about this and
we'll have a safe word you don't know
that you don't know that but this sounds
like so much fun
no because next week I talked about
diseases someone has to say it
space AIDS oh yeah you think a condom is
gonna deal with alien pathogens [ __ ]
what happens when you get alien pregnant
that will be exciting
no no you don't believe that
then I'm stuck with a with a alien baby
literally and I'm starting now a new
species and like I know fascinating
there was somebody impregnated by an
alien that burst out of their chest
that's certainly a concern of mine
there's no way you'd ever be able to get
pregnant from something that doesn't
have the same size as a person if a
horse like wizards that's I can't argue
that how do you know they're not wizards
I think that we should be welcoming and
if they want to have sex with me really
really welcoming the first time you have
sex it's like whoa this is an
opportunity to have that experience
again it may have been bad to fall in
love with somebody of a different race
creed religious background in the past
but some people broke through those
barriers and some people said you know
what love is love you're saying I don't
want to be on the wrong side of history
here yeah that's the argument you don't
know alien and human love could exist
you're the first person in the world
you mean the Christopher Columbus of
having sex with aliens no that's not a
good reference how do you know you
haven't had sex with an alien yet I mean
I'm gonna have sex with it if we if we
connect and then I'm gonna have the
coolest weirdest sex imaginable and you
can't have any of it because I'm too
busy having it would you have sex with
an alien that you weren't in love with
if the alien was hot the fact that
you're thinking about this means that
you're imagining a sexy alien we're just
[ __ ] up in its own doubt of the year
what if it's just like a ball of energy
that just makes you have the most
powerful orgasm you've ever had you'll
never know an orgasm that would be out
of this world that's pretty good you're
just talking about [ __ ] him out of
the gate like oh this alien shows up
it's got two legs 15 holes whatever you
need and then you're gonna go for it I
am I think that's what I do not need 15
holes I need one I want to know like
what you think the actual sex would be
like and I need you to tell me what it's
just either sex it's about 45 seconds
long and I come at the end please don't
let my parents see me say the word come
I wouldn't have sex with nailing just
tell people I have sex with nail in I'm
gonna do this for science I didn't do
this for exploration and I'm gonna do
this because I want to ride a goddamn
spaceship I think this just comes down
to wonderment I really got too much on
my plate right now if aliens do come to
earth I say we can't trust them
be adventurous we're young let's live it
the future of the human race is
completely dependent on us not [ __ ]
this up yeah we might destroy the human
race but we might destroy the human race
by coming up with a better race also
imagine me having sex with 15 holes like
a whack-a-mole game and a headache go
get a smile on your face
[Music]
maybe all aliens are that goats you're
gonna go [ __ ] a goat
I hope [ __ ] alien they look like a
goat I need to [ __ ] the alien girl
before I find out if there's fiberglass
in the goat alien vaginas